Film Courage: Knowing that you love these
characters with edges how did you make them
still make them redeemable, likable in some
way.
Maybe they are not even likable but somehow
the audience is not going to give up on them?
Orson Oblowitz, Filmmaker/Photographer: Because
they are humans, they are just like you and
me, that’s the point.
If you can just get the point across that
these people all sleep, they all eat, they
all breathe oxygen, if you can just get that
little point across I think we can all relate
to that.
It’s so silly but I’ve always thought
about that because I do like these characters
that are a little off, that sometimes do make
bad decisions instead of good decision but
I think if you also show them they’re humans,
they struggle with so many of the same things
we struggle with.
How they are going to pay their rent they
struggle with, how did the parents love them,
they struggle with all of these very human
factors.
If you can just show a little of that I think
we can’t help but relate to them.
I try to show people also small details in
their personal life.
A lot of this new movie is a guy sitting by
himself in a room eating and watching TV because
we all sit in a room and eat.
We all sit by ourselves and watch.
We all have trouble sleeping, well all have
nightmares.
These little things so I think that’s how
you just humanize them through reality.
Also in your more surreal movie you kind of
take that approach where you show there’s
a certain humanity behind that bad decision
making, behind the kind of acting in bad faith
type of decisions.
That’s it for me, if you can just get the
point just for a moment across you can get
away with whatever you want.
There are a lot of irrepressible characters
in cinema that I love.
BAD LIEUTENANT, right?
BAD LIEUTENANT’s Harvey Keitel is the great
example of it in that film but he tries to
at one point he really feels like he’s making
the right decision and you have to show that.
You show the human side to the character and
I think we all will be willing to go for the
ride if it’s also entertaining.
That’s a big part of it as well.
Film Courage: I’d love to see more female
characters like that because Author Margaret
Atwood has a great quote and she says women
are either painted as total angels or as horrible
human beings but they’re human, so there’s
a spectrum.
Whereas it feels like sometimes men can have
more of a gray area but I wish it would show
they don’t have to have such clearly defined
roles…either she’s a bad character or
she’s great but she can’t be anything
in-between.
Orson: Well that was my goal with “Queen.”
[Orson’s film QUEEN OF HOLLYWOOD BLVD).
I wanted to literally take a character that
we were so accustomed with the James Bond’s
or Robert Mitchum’s or Steve McQueen’s
or any of these great male icons that we’ve
had throughout the years and allow a woman
to make those same mistakes.
Allow her to be able to live in that gray
area that you’re talking about.
That was really my goal was to take all these
characters and say why not let a woman be
it.
You know what…you should have heard some
of the irreprehensible things I’ve written
on the Internet about her and it’s because
it’s unfamiliar.
We are in this world where we are so obsessed
with man and woman and women are a lot of
times relegated to these…either they are
these terrible evil you know the woman who
is the psycho crazy woman who destroys everything
or she is the angel, love interest savior
character and there ain’t no difference.
We are all trying to figure this life thing
out together why can’t a woman make the
same decisions a man make’s.
It’s crazy that the media has sold us this
lie for so long.
So Queen one hundred percent and I hope I
landed there.
I’m not sure if I did but I tried to let
her live in this morally gray area and I would
see how it goes.
Film Courage: And these were comments underneath
the trailer or…?
Orson: Just the different comments in the
trailer or things I’ve heard people say
to my face, friends who didn’t even realize
they were kind of saying something that was
beyond…not misogynistic…it’s just unaware
about what they are saying about the character.
“She’s so hard,” “She’s such a witchy
witch.”
And I go really?
Because if James Bond did that you wouldn’t
say that.
If when Ryan Gosling punches the one actors
in the face in DRIVE no one every asked about
it.
No one ever said…but if she does it, if
she slaps another person suddenly she’s
evil, sometimes she is cringe-worthy.
We’ve gotten a lot of great reviews but
we’ve had a few people that really went
of the misogynistic train on the film…and
good…that’s what I wanted.
I want them to show their face.
Show your face, if that’s what you think,
say it.
Film Courage: It’s conversation so then
again you can’t control the outcome of the
film and it lands where it lands.
Questions For The Viewers: How did you like
these thoughts on character?